that's right denise well according to
the director for the immigrant home
foundation he says
it's all about trust they are spreading
the word about the vaccine in under
underserved communities and now their
biggest problem is not having enough
vaccines
now this was a line outside the rafael
rivera community center
of stuart near eastern today the
organization has partnered with walmart
and pfizer
to get the covet 19 vaccine to the
community at the site people who are 65
years or older healthcare workers
educators staff of licensed family care
providers
are all eligible to get vaccinated each
person according to organizers receives
the vaccine without in without an
appointment insurance proof
of immigration status or cost yesterday
on sunday we did 402 vaccines the day
before we did 300
and consistently every day for the past
two weeks we've been giving over 200 per
day
well currently only first doses of the
pfizer vaccine is being administered at
this site
and folks are set up with their second
shot as well now there are many
vaccination sites around the county
where you can go and get your shop but
obviously the first step that you can do
is visit our website eight newsnow dot
com
for all the information just simply
follow the links christian concerto is 8
news now